yes yes sir we have harika in our studio
welcome to Saint Louis haircut so today
the game was not uh about fireworks
probably
um I wanted to ask you how difficult it
is for you to play against hampi
uh I think especially these days so we
are playing with the same team in the
Indian channel for India so of course we
had we have some connect and it is
slightly difficult but of course we are
playing in serious tournaments a game is
a game so were you checking her
preparation today I think that well
judging by the clock you knew the
position perfectly you even had more
time than when you started so uh no
actually I uh I mean I decided to play
Scotch but this model maybe I thought
she wouldn't Place uh with me like in
the classical game she never played so I
didn't prepare and when she played it uh
okay especially I didn't prepare much
because yesterday I was like really
upset after a long game and a good game
I uh it was such a hard luck that this
Rook k6 exists and I I had like some
thousand ways to draw so I decided I'm
not like preparing much and I only saw
like maybe one two hours like keep it
and I decided if it comes okay I'll play
something I played already like I played
this some hun I mean I don't know 100
games online so okay I decided okay if
it's solid if solid black knows
everything it's a draw but so this game
is an opening surprise today
uh I won't say surprise uh but yes like
I gave this least importance
and I played this with black also I like
I had draw I think three years back with
black but I play many games in this
online I played so okay I didn't expect
too much and I didn't want to do
anything new I just played something I
know very well and if it's a draw Etc
and well you talked about the game uh
that you lost yesterday who helps you in
those difficult situations yes myself I
think after all these years of
professional chess I think it's just we
have to help ourselves and uh uh yeah I
mean this just definitely motivates me
to play better chess because I think
I played good decent chess but this I
think the tiredness sometime overtook me
and like when I had best chances I
couldn't calculate accurately especially
because I'm coming from Grand Prix and
like I had a long game on the first day
I was like extremely tired and I think
somewhere I could see that white I
played bad so I forgive myself for that
and I'm moving on and I think today it's
in a way it's good for me that I'll get
some time to rest okay thank you I have
one last question for you because I've
seen the a few players they have some
superstitions so is there any absolutely
rational superstition that you have no I
have many but I don't want to tell on
camera and then everyone will know but
yes I have my knee from I think from a
childhood I had like many superstitions
I'm trying to get over them and like you
know to act mature but still I have some
but I wouldn't want to tell this on
camera to people so that they know
well thank you very much and we wish you
all all the luck you know that you need
for the rest of the tournament thank you
Amir thank you Eureka actually I